hey everyone this is Lucy and today I'm
joined by Alistair who is the cloud
architect at AWS today we're going to be
answering the question what does it take
to become an AWS Cloud architect we'll
also talk about the different ways you
can learn a job as a cloud architect
starting off with no experience so
Alistair you're on the channel a few
months ago and we were talking about the
difference between a Solutions architect
and a cloud architect and after the
video got published a lot of people
became interested in the cloud acting
role so it's great to have you back on
the show today do you want to introduce
yourself again and explain what you do
as a cloud architect sure thanks Lucy
it's really nice to be back on the
channel again hi everyone I'm Alistair
I'm A Cloud architect at AWS based here
in Sydney Australia as part of my role I
work with customers to deliver value and
help accelerate their move to the cloud
I personally focus on cloud foundation's
infrastructure and iot and what that
involves on a day-to-day basis is going
to our specific customers figuring out
their requirements and actually Hands-On
keyboard building with them to help
build their production ready system
items and get them ready to move to the
cloud or enhance some of their already
existing infrastructure to suit their
future business needs it'll be great to
talk about the journey to how I got to
this role today awesome yeah that was
actually going to be my next question
which is how did you land a job as a
cloud architect at AWS do you want to go
through your journey sure so Simmons are
you I came through the techieu program
at AWS so specifically I was focused on
the role of the cloud architect I was an
associate Cloud architect when I joined
and over the course of six months I went
through the specific training to
understand how we work at AWS
introduction about the cloud and
actually all about how we communicate
with customers so then after the six
months I came out still an associate
Cloud architect but with the building
blocks to be able to actually start in
the role since then I've been building
up working in front of customers and
working with my team members to actually
build the skills and enablement to
understand how to properly work with a
customer and that leaves me where I am
at today a cloud architect for AWS great
thank you so much for explaining your
journey into AWS so what are some other
ways people can become a cloud architect
I know for both of us we came from the
early career pathway which is the techu
program but for those who are interested
in becoming a cloud architect starting
with no Cloud experience how can they go
about it sure so I have a lot of
colleagues from various different
backgrounds that have joined our team
and become Cloud Architects and the two
main parts are either from becoming
another role in AWS or joining from a
consultancy background because in the
end that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to understand the customer's
problem and provide them with solutions
to be able to solve those problems and
build business value so the first one
coming from another AWS role people have
come from support roles Cloud engineer
roles and even solution Architects all
of them have built up the experience of
what AWS is and are experts in their
fields they can come along to our team
and provide Great Value into delivering
specific areas of our business and
providing specific value to what we
deliver they may need to build up and
bridge that smaller gap of how they
communicate with customers but they are
very well versed in the AWS Cloud
already on the other hand we have quite
a few people who come from a Consulting
background already those people are well
aware of how to actually engage with
customers understand their problems and
come back to them with Solutions the
area that they may need to improve on
once they get here is just understanding
what products and services AWS have in a
bit more depth because coming in and
understanding aws's culture is a really
big and important thing for us no matter
which path they come through people come
with a wide range of experience but they
still need to improve their skills to be
able to become a fully fledged Cloud
architect and naturally that comes over
time those are some really interesting
Pathways and I've definitely seen the
cloud architects in AWS come from those
so do people need to come from a
tactical background if they want to
become a cloud architect alright so one
way to build your skills and become a
cloud architect is to attend the cloud
bootcamp simply learn has launched a
cloud computing bootcamp in
collaboration with Celtic University
this bootcamp provides live classes
taught by experienced instructors and by
the end of it you receive a certificate
of completion every year the demand for
professionals with AWS Cloud skills
continues to increase and here you can
see the marker growth and average
salaries for roles in the cloud industry
the course curriculum covers a wide
range of cloud Concepts in both Azure
and AWS and you'll get to work on four
industry projects there's a three-stage
application process for The Bootcamp
where first of all you submit an
application then you wait for it to get
reviewed and selected candidates can
then begin the program within one to two
weeks the next cohort starts soon with
limited spots available so make sure you
take a look at the reviews and check out
the link to the course in the video
description below so do people need to
come from a tactical background if they
want to become a cloud Architect no
certainly not a lot of people have
joined our teams from various different
Majors back in University some from
marine biology to ethics to history the
biggest skill to become a cloud
architect is the ability to be able to
communicate with our customers and
understand their problems a lot of what
we deliver can be taught those technical
skills are important but you can develop
those over time it's better to come in
understanding how to communicate with
our customers and our teams and then
building up those skills from then on
nice okay I'm sure it's definitely very
reassuring for the viewers to hear that
you don't have to come
pick up what advice do you have for
people who are interested in becoming a
cloud architect sure I'd probably break
it down into three things first of all
Cloud knowledge you can never go wrong
there understanding the basics of the
cloud and of the basics of some of our
key Services how they work and how you
interact with them and always on top of
that going ahead and building on AWS to
actually have that in-depth knowledge a
cloud architect is a Hands-On keyboard
technical role in the end you actually
do need to deliver content for our
customers so being able to understand a
problem and creating that proof of
concept is really important and finally
I'd say double down on those
interpersonal skills being able to
communicate with a large audience or
individuals at various times is really
important you need to be able to
communicate with the engineers on the
ground and oftentimes to the ctOS and
the executives as well because how we
communicate the value of the product is
so much more important than actually
delivering the tech itself so overall
there's many different ways to get into
the role of a cloud architect at AWS yes
technical knowledge and interpersonal
knowledge is going to help along the way
but don't think there's any one specific
path if you're Keen about helping
customers and building and delivering
awesome technology then you are
certainly on track to becoming a cloud
architect wow that's super inspiring and
I hope that encourages some of our
viewers to explore the canal Arctic role
in the future so this brings us to the
end of this video of what it takes to
become an AWS Cloud architect thank you
so much Alistair for joining today thank
you so much for having me back on your
Channel today please give this video a
like if you've got something out of it
and leave your questions in the comments
below low alright bye for now